hello everyone
welcome to the developments in wolfram
alpha notebook edition talk
my name is paco jane i'm a research
programmer with wolfram alpha
and uh i was responsible for hooking up
the demonstrations that you'll see here
um and also some of the back end for
wolfe from function repository items
um the other my two co-presenters are
peter faloon and jeremy stratton smith
and they can go ahead and introduce
themselves
hi i'm peter fallon i'm a consultant for
wolfram research
based in paris western australia my main
work has been
in the area of session references which
i'll be talking about today
as well as geometry and math
input great um my name is jeremy
stratton smith i'm
a wolf i'm a math developer for wolfram
alpha
and uh my primary area of work for wolfe
from alpha notebook edition has been the
function repository
and um
hooking up uh function repository items
as we will see
um as i'll talk about in a little bit
okay thanks um so just to remind those
of you who
um may not be aware wolfram alpha
notebook edition
is a product that was created about a
year ago it combines the natural
language
processing power of wolfram alpha with
the
notebook sort of flow development um
environment that's so popular these days
and has been in the wolfram language for
a long time
um so what is i'm gonna start talking
about demonstrations
uh what is demonstration so
demonstrations
there's something called the wolfram
demonstrations project that's been going
on for
about over a decade um where we've uh
solicited from the public
anyone can submit interactive code that
will
demonstrate as the name implies some um
it could be anything really it could be
uh
for instance here let's look at this
category called
multiple demonstrations
and the main part of uh what what
uh the main part of what is presented
here
is one of the wolfram language is a
manipulate object
and uh for those of you who have seen
these before
um manipulates allow you to change
parameters
change variables and see how your
results will change and this can be very
useful in a pedagogical
uh environment in order to
show things that you know are better
shown
hands in a hands-on way let me change
this
to standard form
there's just a little bit of a
an issue when you're looking at these in
traditional form but let's take a look
at one of these things rotation matrix
matrix indices we've made um
getting a notebook representation of
these things
very easy by clicking on these
orange buttons you see
and you can see
that after clicking that button i'm
going to get a window opened up
here i clicked on change of bases in 2d
so this is an example of something you
might be drawing on a chalkboard in your
traditional math class
but of course in these days in this day
and age you know you've got
maybe electronic whiteboard or maybe
you're doing a zoom meeting
and you want to be able to demonstrate
these types of things to your students
in a you know
in a dynamic and visually
engaging way so that's basically what a
demonstration is and you can see it
comes with text it comes with
uh related links to other things in the
will from world and also
source code so you could even modify
this to your heart's content
these are also available on the
wolframdemonstrations.com
excuse me demonstration.wolfram.com
website but uh
the nice thing here is that we've got
access right here in the wolfram alpha
notebooks
with natural language um just to show
you a few of my
personal favorites you know um i like to
think of these as
examples of where you could where maybe
in your classroom you'd be doing a lab
or some other type of group activity
that has become harder
in our sort of work from home
school from home um situation and
this can hopefully help with teaching
so like blood type inheritance we've all
played with these probably in high
school or college
with inheritance and you can just simply
see how things work that's what this is
all about demonstrating
um i'll just show you another one here
because
it's kind of like a virtual lab
situation
there is an issue when these are
presented in a traditional form they
don't work so well but
you know something like this
is a nice hands-on sort of thing
all right moving on i'm going to talk
about another domain chemistry which is
not somewhere that i've worked directly
there's we have our wolfram alpha
chemistry team made of
two jason's and they have developed all
of this nice stuff
um sorry i thought this was going to be
pre-populated
um and i just wanted to show you these
pictures so
you know even though wolf from alpha
notebook edition is thought of
you know you might think of wolfram as
in general a mathematical sort of
um piece of software but you can see
there's biology there's
chemistry there's all sorts of
interesting stuff that we're adding and
we're adding linguistics so that people
have easy access to them what is the
chemical formula of melatonin
for instance all right with that i'm
going to uh
hand over the talk to peter peter i'm
gonna stop sharing go ahead
okay thanks baku so um i'm gonna now
talk a little bit about session
references in muffin alpha notebook
edition
um and to illustrate the basic idea i'm
just gonna walk through a very
simple series of calculation steps um
which will kind of illustrate what what
i'm talking about when i'm when i say
session references so to begin um
i'm going to define a variable y in
terms of
a polynomial involving a variable x then
i'm going to define another variable z
in terms of also in terms of x and now
what i want to do is a calculation that
refers to
y and z and so here i ask what is y
times z
okay so this seems pretty
straightforward and obvious but
what's going on under the hood here is
we're actually making use
of the fact that we've defined y and z
so y and z have a definition in our
current session
and so when we talk about session
references we're talking about this kind
of functionality
the ability to refer to a variable or a
previous
output and one final step here i can say
expand this
and the keyword here this is interpreted
as again a session reference this time
referring to the result of the previous
calculation
so the use of session references either
variables or
outputs is sort of fundamental to the
ability to build up a calculation in a
series of steps as this example is kind
of illustrated
i'm just going to very quickly talk
about what are the kind of linguistics
that are supported in some of the issues
firstly for locally defined variables so
the y and the z
and the above example um it's pretty
self-explanatory that if the variable's
name is y that's how you're going to
refer to it
however there's a couple of potential
gotchas um
firstly if you want to define a variable
involving subscripts this is supported
so x subscript 1 x
subscript 2. you'll notice that
obviously we don't then
want to enter that in natural language
in the same way that it appears in
so the explicit use of the underscore
to denote the subscript is recommended
there um
a second case that can cause some
confusion is whenever your symbol names
happen to coincide with built-in symbols
in the woofer language
so capital c and capital d both have
meaning in the movement language as
um constant and derivative operators
respectively
so what we do to get around this we
actually interpret
uh your c and d as scripted characters
um
and that kind of conversion is done sort
of invisibly to the
to you the user um so you can continue
having to find those variables
to refer to them as regular c and
regular d
and uh wolfman alpha notebook does the
conversion
um for you if on the other hand you
wanted to copy
you know realistically the way you would
probably end up here is if you had
copied an output and pasted um
that's also supported
so this is just a kind of a convenience
mapping from uh you know regular
regular uppercase characters to scripted
ones whenever the regular ones
are clashing with language syntax
um things are a little bit more varied
for uh references that refer
to previous outputs so here's another
example so you know expand
something um we might then ask
to subtract one from this so again this
is playing the rule of a reference to
the previous output
and that works as you'd expect um in
addition to that you can also use
wu from language syntax for referring to
previous outputs so the percentage
symbol
um is probably the most common way to do
that
also relative out references so out
minus one
is referring to the previous output
finally out
with the number of the input so here um
this previous output was number 14. so
i'm going to say factorize out 14
and that should just work good so so
that's
a few different ways you can refer to
previous outputs
in your session um just a quick comment
that
the wolfram language syntax is the most
precise here and you know it's
recommended if you're going to start
doing things that involve
multiple uh the results of multiple
different evaluations this is the
cleanest way to
ensure that you get what you're
expecting um
just a quick comment on definitions
obviously a lot of this
session reference stuff relies on you
being able to define symbols or
functions
um one thing that the design
choice that was made is that when you do
an expression like y equals x squared
that gets interpreted as an equality
rather than a definition for y
um and the recommended kind of preferred
way if you want to actually insist on
making a definition rather than
an equality is to prepend a keyword like
let or also things like define
will work and when you do that
you get a definition for why
also if you want to define a function as
opposed to just a variable
the thing to do is to put the argument
on the left-hand side just as you would
when you're writing mathematical
mutation and
you'll see here that this gets correctly
interpreted as a function definition
with the
underscored symbol on the left-hand side
okay so that's basically session
references function definitions
um a lot of the work that's ongoing in
this area involves
basically trying to make um the roof
alphanumeric programs
a bit smarter about how it interprets
what your reference
is and how it should be used and a
couple of examples to illustrate the
kind of
issues that are involved here um firstly
matrix inverses so
let me go ahead and define a two by two
matrix
and then ask for the inverse of this
matrix
and not too surprisingly the result
you're going to get is the
mathematical language inverse function
okay but what about if your matrix is
not
square in which case the inverse
function
doesn't apply in that case
we actually are able to recognize that
the matrix is a square
and instead we give you the
pseudo-inverse function um
so that's sort of showing you that the
interpretation of what it means to
invert
your previous result or in this case
your variable n is a function
of what kind of expression it is
another placement this is quite
important is in plotting so if i just
do some function here something sine of
x squared
and then asked to plot this
the result you get is the mathematical
plot function which is the right thing
given that this is an algebraic
expression
however if instead of an algebraic
expression you had a list of numbers
as your input so here i've just done
sine of k squared for range of k values
um and you're asked to plot that
obviously the plot function wouldn't be
much help
and so what we return is the list plot
function
um and so you can imagine that for like
you know there's
lots of different things that would uh
necessitate different types of plot
function and so
it helps that we have this kind of
awareness of what type of
result or what type of input you're
trying to feed into the plot
so um how does this work i'm just going
to give some very
sort of basic um sort of ideas here to
sort of
to give you some kind of idea of of
what's going on under the hood
and sort of hopefully help give you some
understanding if and when you encounter
issues
where things maybe aren't just behaving
as you might expect
um so firstly just the distinction that
i think is helpful to draw is
there's basically two evaluations going
on in the wolf alpha notebook
the first one is the what we call the
parsing
of your natural language expression so
this involves sending
your natural language query to our roof
alpha servers and
uh parsing it just like roof and off
using the same engine that will from
alpha is using
to convert your natural language query
into a movement language expression
okay that then gets sent back to your
local session where it gets evaluated
using the
wolfram language kernel
and so right away you can see that
there's a potential issue here because
the natural language conversion is
happening on the wolfram language server
and not inside your local session and
that means that a lot of the information
the contextual information about your
session is not available to the wolfman
alpha server
and so the sort of way that we get
around this the way we make this work is
to actually send a certain amount of
information with your
natural language query to the movement
alpha server
and for those who are curious i'm just
going to give you a peek at what this
actually looks like
so let me define two matrices again and
i'm going to
invert each of these just like i did
above see we get inverse of a
and c to inverse for b which is not
um square okay clearly we've sent
something some information about
the matrices a and b in order to make
this work and
the way you can find out is the woof
alpha function
which has been a part of wolf language
for um at least i think since version
seven or eight
um you can actually ask for the session
info
field um for this you get this kind of
uh fairly intractable looking expression
here but the
thing to notice is that what is getting
sent here is
a bunch of different things and one of
them is a list of the relevant symbols
okay and we can see the symbol a here
for this particular case a is a fairly
small expression so we actually
send the value of a which is the
complete expression
um if a was a much larger list then this
value field wouldn't be sent because it
would make our
url too big in addition to the value
we have the head of the expression we
have dimensions
and we have a list of these things
called semantic types and the semantic
types are what really drives a lot of
this functionality because
you know regardless of the size of the
expression in suitcases where the value
is not available
the semantic types give us the
information we need to
sort of intelligently determine which
type of function
should be returned and you'll see just
by way of comparison that for
the case of b the list of semantic types
is slightly different so there's not a
see here there's a numeric square matrix
a square matrix
um in the case of b which is not a
square matrix we don't have those
semantic types present okay so thanks
very much i
will now hand over to jeremy who will
continue
fantastic thanks peter um if i can
get the screen share
quickly um i'm going to be talking about
um using well from function repository
items in
wolfenhoff notebook um so the basic idea
of this is that um
as paco said in wolfram alpha notebook
edition we have access to
all of the power of the wolfram alpha
natural language parser which is really
great um but
on the website for those of you who are
familiar with wolfram alpha
when you give an input it's very likely
that you'll get
more than one pod of information out and
we ran into an issue of how do we
how do we capture those very specific
pods
and potentially multiple pods per input
into one single output in wolfram alpha
notebook edition
so um these sort of highly specific
computations that
maybe don't quite fit in with the
overall wolfram language design
um are things that we've been able to
wrap up and put into these function
repository items
so first here we see we have a plot this
is a very standard sort of calculus
thing
okay we see two curves and we want to
find out what's the area of this little
region
in between here um so we can ask for the
area between
x and x squared which is something that
on the web you
um would not only get this result but
you would also get the plot
together um but here because there isn't
a built-in wolfram language function to
compute this
um using some integrals um we have
wrapped that up into
this resource function area between
curves which is accessible to anybody
even outside of um well from alpha
notebook edition but
is it makes for a nice concise statement
that
we are able to compute here
in addition to these highly highly
specific
computations we are also able to
provide some uh summaries of information
that
are similar to what you might find on
the web so another
function repository item curve fit
report here um
we we parse to this curve fit report and
then we get not only
the uh equation for the fit but a plot
and a whole bunch of other information
that um
a student wanting to a student in
uh high school or in uh college
statistics class might want to um know
um so sometimes we have these nicely
formatted
grids in other cases we
are returning an association of
information so in this case we have a
number of different
forms of this tangent line to um
the curve y equals x squared and we have
some more information about it the slope
the intercepts
um a plot and um
so on so in this way we're able to take
take a sort of complicated
um or or potentially somewhat vague
input and return a lot of information
um akin to what what's happening on the
web
um a lot of these function repository
items have also been designed
with wolfram language syntax in mind so
that
something like this where we are we're
implying that we want a dynamic output
um not only are we now able to have an
interactive output which is something we
can't have on the web
but we're also introducing users to um
sort of the conventions of wolfram
language syntax which this manipulate
plot
merges the the syntax of both the plot
function and the manipulate function so
you can see
our manipulator variables here in
addition to our plot range
um and then also be able to interact
with this
in um in the ways that you
we aren't necessarily able to do on the
web
um which makes for great um
interactive lessons we're also able to
take things
um like the sort of standard calculus
task of identifying all of the
interesting points
and properties of a curve and we're able
to dynamically
do that here with this particular
curve analysis function
and we're able to show all of the
relevant information as well as
again a nicely formatted set of code
here
that presents all of the things that
we're able to see here
and more um so we can talk about the
domain the range period etc
um so in this way the the using these
function repository items really
makes it possible to take a single input
and
provide as much content as we can and
really make use of the fact that we
are working in a notebook so that
there's interactivity available
and all the things that make a notebook
great to work with similarly just to
highlight um as
peter has already been talking about the
session references um
these uh wfrs or wolfram function
repository items also
um will work with our session references
so that we
we assign this definition to f here and
we're able to get the vertical
and um horizontal asymptotes out
so um that's that's a little brief
overview of the way that we're using
these function repository items
um these will continue to be we'll
continue to add support for these over
the coming years
um and they are a really great way to
to consolidate
the content into a single function and
make it accessible to
outside users so um for our future work
in the next year you can
look forward to hopefully having
multi-line inputs everything you've seen
here has been
a single line per input cell and so we
might be adding support for
multiple lines within the same input
cell um
and additionally we're excited to be to
be working on
adding 2d inputs so um the kind of
things that you saw with peter
where there was the special notation for
subscripts um
hopefully soon we'll be able to have um
the like 2d fractions and powers
and all of the all of the nice um
type setting for particularly for math
that
you're able to get in a normal notebook
um that will hopefully be
able to be um input directly into the
natural language input cell there
um we'll also be developing a
demonstrations browser so that
um the content that paco was introducing
at the beginning will be
made even easier um to access which will
be really great
and um as you all as as the end users
continue
to interact with wolfe from alpha
notebook edition it tells us
what things you all are interested in so
there's there's ongoing content
improvements because this
does rely on the the wolfram alpha
technology this is constantly improving
um and it isn't on the same release
schedule as
uh the or many features are not on the
same release schedule as
um the mathematic or proper so we're
able to to update things much more
um in a much more live fashion
um so as you all use the product we're
able to
see what what areas need improvement and
what you all want so
we encourage you to continue using
welcome off another edition
thank you so much for joining us today
and um feel free to reach out to
any any of the three of us if you have
more questions
um or comments about the the um
presentation or wolfram off a notebook
edition in general
so thanks and i'll stop sharing here